a história começa mais ou menos assim 27
de um de 2019 destruição total carros
bombeiros helicópteros no ar
policiais em uma cidade totalmente
devastada pela lama
e aí nesse meu primeiro contato
encontrei alguns amigos nessa dessa
viagem em que eles também eram
fotógrafos fotógrafos da globo doj
nacional geographic e eu nessa minha
caminhada como fotógrafo seguir eles
eles falaram bom agora a gente está indo
para o córrego do feijão siga você quer
com a gente e eu fui com eles
seguindo com o do feijão pra gente essa
lama a gente precisava dar uma caminhada
pela mata de mais ou menos 20 minutos
então a gente caminhar pela mata e eu
acho que houve uma das cenas mais
tristes da minha vida dele que é um mar
de lama assim onde não tem fim e quando
eu cheguei naquele lugar onde tinham
vários fotógrafos eram um mar de
fotógrafos todos esperando a próxima
cena o que acontecer e eu fiquei meio
chocada com aquilo
eu me perguntei aqui é o meu lugar e com
tantas tantas fotos tantas coisas
acontecendo ali eu realmente teve um
choque de realidade
voltei pra cidade do conjunto feijão eu
estava sozinho e e procurava um lugar
para dormir porque o hotel tinha sido
devastado
fui batendo de porta em porta
perguntando quem podia me acolher e eu
conhecia o seu vicente assim o seu
recente ele me acolheu e lhe falou andré
aqui você pode ficar na minha casa e vou
te servir o melhor que eu tenho pra você
bom eu queria passar algumas fotos de
quando cheguei em brumadinho
essa foi a primeira história que eu
contei
essa é a mata que a gente passou para
chegar até o lugar da lama
é muito arriscado a lama ela consome ela
tipo é perigosa
você não pode encostar nela aqui é um
policial 11 que eu encontrei logo que eu
cheguei eu perguntei pra ele qual é a
sensação que você tem aqui ele me disse
cenário de guerra
realmente é um cenário de guerra mesmo
sem ter participado da guerra a gente
conseguia ver os bombeiros então acessar
e chegar até a lama chegar até alguma
nesse caso estão chegando até a vaca que
estava atrás disso nesse monte
são cenas assim que eu vivi os oitos
dias que eu passei por lá
essa é uma parte que a vaca estava sendo
carregada e já ia me esquecendo mais me
chamou mé sou formado em cinema da faap
e eu trabalho contando a história de
pessoas pessoas invisíveis que acontece
com tem mais de 800 histórias na cidade
de são paulo sobre moradores de rua e
foi isso que me fez ir pra armadinho eu
sabia que ali existiam pessoas
invisíveis também mas não sabe onde elas
estavam
e foi isso que me confundiu muito logo
que eu cheguei porque a lama ela invade
invadir os seus olhos toma conta quando
alguém toma conta da sua visão você
esquece aqueles que são mais importantes
que não estão sendo vistos que vou
contar pra vocês aqui agora
são histórias que vocês não viram na tv
porque elas não foram contadas mas eu
sei o que vocês viram
vocês viram o ônibus sendo aberto e os
bombeiros tirando as pessoas lá dentro
vocês viram a vaca sendo içada
vocês viram aquela cena que o
helicóptero desce bem baixinho e pega
uma sim uma mulher está no meio da lama
ninguém falou o nome dele né mas quem
salvou ele salvou ela foi jefferson
o gef e superou 40 minutos até que o
helicóptero encontrar aquela mulher ali
ele ficou segurando ela bom sou eu
nesse tempo que eu passei lá eu escutei
muitas histórias
eu escutei cerca de 46 41 histórias
dessas 41 histórias
eu contei 20 nas redes sociais e nessas
histórias foram importantes para que
mais pessoas pudessem ver o outro lado
do que está em brumadinho
bom essa aqui também foi uma das cenas
que você provavelmente não viram que é
de um corpo sendo carregado
os bombeiros se preparando pra pra voar
essa é a base onde tinha igrejinha e ali
tinham os o sami à imprensa ficava ali
atrás mais ou menos esse é o jefferson
que tinha falado e aqui começa a contar
minha primeira história
esse senhor onofre o senhor onofre tem
60 e 64 anos nasceu em brumadinho mais
especificamente no córrego do feijão
senhor onofre
ele estava ele trabalhou muito tempo na
mina ele era um daqueles caras que
carregava o carrinho eo na noite passada
do dia 25 que foi o dia que a barragem
rompeu o sobrinho dele chegou na casa
dele
comer macarrão que ele tinha preparada e
o sobrinho dele a moça macarrão porque
ele nunca tinha feito ele falou muito
obrigado senhor sofre
eu quero voltar sempre aqui mas a
verdade é que sempre nunca aconteceu
porque depois desse dia o seu onofre
nunca mais viu o sobrinho dele senão
ficava em frente à casa que eu estava me
a sensação que estava procurando alguma
coisa essa coisa não chegava
ele estava perto da porta ele caminhava
e de um lado para o outro e essa era a
cena todos os dias ele estava assim mas
é sempre assim quando a gente olha uma
história ela parece triste
mas quanto mais próxima a gente chega
dela a gente pode perceber que essa
história é muito triste
senhor onofre chorou comigo e não foi
uma zona que as pessoas que foram mais
de 30 dessas 40 que acontece aos 40 que
conta a história eu muitas vezes é a
primeira pessoa que aquele que aquele
que aquela pessoa tinha conversado
depois o que tinha acontecido
conversei com a mãe que já tinha perdido
seu marido que tinha duas filhas para
criar
e ela falou que tinha perdido a irmã e
sem esperança
não sabia se ia continuar na cidade e
nesses oito dias que fiquei lá ele foi
dividido em duas partes a primeira parte
foi fiquei quatro dias e o meu objetivo
era contar a história aquelas pessoas
para que todo mundo possa usgs
elas mas o meu último dia lá quando já
estava descansando eu estava exausto
porque aquilo consome mesmo eu sentei no
centro da cidade
no chão e um senhor se aproximou de mim
comecei a conversar com ele e senhoras e
wilson
o senhor wilson é um homem muito
simpático muito simples começou a contar
a minha história dele
eu nem estava ali pra isso mas mas ele
fez questão de contar e olha se não
tivesse contado aquela história não
teria voltado programa dinheiro por que
o senhor wilson ele tem um filho tem
síndrome de down e naquela situação onde
tudo é difícil
o filho com síndrome de down se torna
mais difícil ainda mas isso não impedirá
ele jamal filho e de lutar por ele tudo
que ele podia fazer de fazer pelo filho
dele e o senhor wilson e ele me contando
do filho dele eu falei eu quero conhecer
o seu filho já que ele está
o primeiro levou até a casa dele em uma
casa simples triste
é a gente não tem noção assim do que
isso um dia que você vive todo dia e à
estrutura quase zero
cheguei lá com esse lado o lázaro uma
criança incrível
sorridente carismática disco diz o que
pensa que trata o pai muito bem muito
educada
eu fiquei realmente impressionado com
aquela família e eu não tinha ido lá pra
isso mas eu perguntei pra pro azar o
qual é o seu sonho lá do outro lado ela
me disse meu sonho é uma cadeira de
rodas elétrica porque o meu pai já está
com 67 anos ele não consegue mais me
carregar
eu dependo muito dele para fazer as
coisas e esse meu problema motor na mão
e no pé não me deixa me locomover pela
cidade quando como quando escutei isso
eu vi que podia fazer alguma coisa
diferente de muitas histórias que eu
tinha escutado ali que eu não podia
fazer nada para a maioria delas
ali houve esperança eu voltei pra casa
criei uma campanha nas redes sociais
contando a história do lázaro
quando eu contei a história do lázaro
eu não queria que as pessoas
simplesmente doassem mas que ela tivesse
o privilégio de doar para alguma coisa
que ajudar realmente alguém então vou eu
então deixei essa campanha no ar mais ou
menos cinco dias de cinco dias eu
consegui alcançar a meta que era de
arrecadar 35 mil reais e agora está com
uma história na mão um sonho na mão que
podia ser realizada
então voltei pro miudinho e tentei
disfarçar o senhor wilson faleceu eu só
vim aqui saber como é que estão
caminhando com ele até a casa dele e
chegando lá ele encontrou a cadeira de
rodas elétrica que ele queria
aquilo mudou a vida dele eu acho que
nunca vi uma uma família tão feliz
depois disso
bom essa história do senhor wilson e do
lazer
eu não tenho outra pessoa depois de
brumadinho eu não sou o mesmo andré
eu não esperava encontrar tudo isso eu
não sabia nem o que vou encontrar
eu não tava assistindo noticiário quando
eu fui mas aquelas histórias mudar a
minha vida e espero que ela possa mudar
de vocês também
se vocês quiserem conhecer mais
histórias podem acessar o arroba
invisível e conhecer mais de várias
histórias
obrigada